while appearing on a show that lowers
the collective IQ of the nation by at
least one standard deviation the view
Ally Wentworth who's the wife of ABC
News objective news anchor George
Stephanopoulos explained what election
night was like at the Stephanopoulos
Wentworth home here's what it looked
like and I have an 11 year old daughter
who doesn't really understand what Isis
is but she knows that she's scared and
she's now sleeping in bed with us every
night which what do you do Alec what do
you say what do you do you got little
girls you you see what's happening what
can what can you say that other parents
who have who are at their wit's end with
their children who are scared and
they're also scared as adults this is
what I say I say two things I say to my
kids one is we help out everybody in
this country that is really going to
need our help
whatever whatever in organization you
know we we give we volunteer we help out
well as my my 14 year old getting upset
about the election and screaming no
abortions really loudly 14 year old and
I was like you haven't kissed a boy yet
don't use that word so quickly but okay
let's just point something out if you're
wondering why the left have gone
completely insane perhaps it's because
they were raised to be insane another
raising their kids the exact same way
why in the world when a
fourteen-year-old girl think that her
world is ending because Donald Trump has
been elected president more importantly
why would she think her world is ending
because of possible restrictions on
abortion she's 14 are left his parents
truly raising their daughters to believe
that their right to freedom is dependent
on their ability to kill their own
offspring in the womb I'll raise my kids
to believe that certain rights are
sacred the right to religious practice
the right to freedom of speech the right
to defend ourselves the notion of
teaching a little girl that abortion is
the chief right women should expect from
their government or that their life is
somehow inevitably impacted by laws
cracking down on abortion that's
patently crazy the fact that someone
left us apparently teach their kids that
Liberty can be boiled down not to
individual choice and responsibility for
that choice but to the ability to pay a
clinic to kill a baby in the womb and
then take it out that's pretty
disgusting as the parents of a daughter
here's what I plan to tell her about
abortion I plan to say sweetheart when
you get married and when you have sex
and get pregnant that will be the
greatest joy you can experience I know
that because it was the greatest joy
that your mom and I ever experienced
your birth was the highlight of our
lives your existence is a timeless
reminder that God loves us and he loves
and that he favors us with miracles
every day none greater than your
creation your beloved of God and your
children will be two children are the
greatest gift we can receive to spurn
that gift to destroy another human life
is a great evil no matter any
countervailing concerns now here's what
they were religious but even if we
weren't that lecture wouldn't change all
that much children are the greatest
thing in life and they are lives
regardless of whether you're religious
or secular and suggesting that true
freedom lies in the ability to kill
children in the womb it's just disgust
it means gross come on propagandizing
fourteen year olds with that suggestion
that's even more gross but if you tell
your kids that evil Republicans are
coming in the nighttime raid your womb
it's no wonder they get hysterical when
Democrats lose elections i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show alright
he's so much to get to today so much
leftist craziness out there i mean we've
been focusing a lot on sort of the
soul-sucking that's been happening in
certain parts of the Republican Party
but there's so much that's crazy that's
happening on the left we're gonna get to
that in just a second but first we have
to say hello to our sponsors at helix
sleep so if you go to helix sleep comm
slash Ben this is the place to go to get
the most comfortable mattress in the
world we have a one of these helix sleep
mattresses and they are just fantastic
the way that it works you go to helix
sleep calm and they ask you for your
height and weight and your body type and
what kind of mattress you like sleeping
on do you like it to absorb heat do you
like it to be cool do you like it to be
more firm or more soft and they can even
make mattresses that are different for
the different sides of the bed so if you
or your partner have different sleep
behaviors then then you can change the
the mattress that way they then send it
to your house in a giant box and and you
unwrap the box and it inflates and it's
yeah it's super cool it's very very
comfortable apparently they've done
surveys and they found that sleep
quality increases like 30 percent based
on sleeping on a helix sleep mattress
really nice mattress they run that 3d
biomechanical model of your body through
algorithms they've developed and then if
you don't like it you can try it for for
a hundred nights and then you can send
it back for free if you don't love it no
questions asked for 100% refund so it's
a great service helix sleep comm slash
spending at $50 off your order helix
sleep comm slash men and their prices
are extraordinarily competitive very
very reasonable the quality of the
mattress is
really good I know because I sleep on
one every single night okay so as you
mentioned you just saw Ally Wentworth
talked about her daughter and it really
is amazing how many people on the left
teach their kids that Republicans are to
be feared and hated because Republicans
oppose abortion because Republicans
don't like babies being killed in the
womb and again I think that children
innately understand what kids are and
they innately understand there's a baby
in mommy's tummy
I know this because right now we have a
seven month old and we have in almost
three year old and three year old knew
all the way through the the pregnancy
that there was a baby in mommy's tummy I
mean she's to walk around the house with
a little doll under her shirt saying
that she was pregnant just like mommy
when kids understand this but adults are
trained they trained themselves not to
understand certain basic truths about
life so that they can do what's
convenient this is making a nation of
crazy people and it really is dividing
us along lines that don't need division
you know there was a question somebody
put out on Twitter must have been a few
weeks ago where they said what's the
thing where in a hundred years people
are gonna look back on American politics
and say I can't believe that was even a
debate this is the one this is the one
he's a science gets better as we see
into the womb better as we it is clear
to people what exactly is going on
inside the womb what happens in
pregnancy as more people become aware of
it people are going to see this for the
evil that it is again the idea of a
fourteen-year-old runarounds running
around screaming because she won't be
able to get an abortion under Trump
number one it's not true number two even
if it were true how about mommy says to
her sweetheart you're never gonna want
an abortion and abortion is bad and
actually what you should be focused on
is making the decisions in your life and
not your ability to kill a baby you know
the idea that your lifestyle is
compromised because you have a baby it's
just it's its stomach churning and the
basic notion the left promotes with
regard to abortion that your lifestyle
must be preserved at the cost of another
human life is life is really really
stomach-turning that's not the only
stomach-churning thing though the left
proclaims itself a big fan of human
rights and in the big news story of the
day is what's happening in Aleppo in
Syria so Aleppo as Gary Johnson well
knows now is a city in Syria it's a lot
but that's what it is and Aleppo has
been the site of a raging battle that's
been taking place over the course of
several months between rebels against
Bashar Assad and the Assad regime the
Russians back Assad the Russian
have been lending support to Assad to go
in and slaughter his own people and the
reports out of out of out of Aleppo are
becoming increasingly insane we're
talking about there's a report yesterday
the 20 women had committed suicide in
order to avoid being raped by Assad's
forces apparently there are a hundred
schoolchildren who are who were killed
but when they were when they were
suffocated under a building that was
blown up by Assad's forces the UN is
saying that there are scores and scores
of people who are civilians who are
being killed in Aleppo and the Obama
administration is just devastated about
this and so they sent out Samantha power
who's the UN Ambassador and who by the
way wrote a book about American in
action during genocide I mean that's her
claim to fame her actual book is about
this which is an incredible thing right
I mean the fact is the issues appointed
specifically because of her
unwillingness to stand by blindly
supposedly when genocide was occurring
the book was called a problem from
hell's big bestseller back in like 2002
and it explicitly talked about American
inaction it goes through all of the the
various genocides that have happened
around the planet during the last
hundred years and gets very upset with
the United States for not stepping in
the New York Times Book Review talked
about her book at the time and it said
this in Washington is a place of
defeatism inertia selfishness and
cowardice warnings pass up the chain to
disappear intelligence is gathered and
then ignored or denied the will of the
executive remains steadfastly opposed to
intervention it's guiding assumption is
that the cost of stopping genocide is
great while the political cost of
ignoring it is next to nil and then
basically she makes the case that we
ought to be more interested in genocide
around the world well the Obama
administration obviously didn't care
about the genocide those happening in
Syria and it is a genocide I mean you're
talking hundreds of thousands of people
dead the way assessment is four hundred
seventy thousand people dead in in Syria
and several million have been exiled
from Syria the entire refugee crisis in
Europe is largely due to what's
happening in Syria Obama as you recall
he said that he drew a red line if Assad
had used chemical weapons against his
own people then Assad did use chemical
weapons against his own people and Obama
said that he was going to take military
action there's blowback to that then he
said he was gonna do what John Kerry
called
a pinprick strike we're just going hey
won't be hover it'll be tiny it'll be
like a needle and then Putin comes along
and says you know what I'll kind of deal
on behalf of Bashar Assad we'll get rid
of some of these WMDs they didn't and we
will make sure that Assad is kept under
control they didn't and Obama jumps on
that he said sure of lad you lead the
way you lead the way of Latin Vladimir
Putin says excellent and then he
proceeds to enshrine Assad work with
Iran to enshrine Assad right now and a
lot of the rebels and on one side you
have the Iranian militias who are going
in there to slaughter everybody on the
other side you have Assad's people who
are going in there to slaughter
everybody and the Obama administration
claiming all the way through that this
is totally wild how could this have
possibly happen here is Samantha Power's
that the lady who wrote this book
literally about American non
intervention during genocides and and
she's being feeded by the media the
media think she is just wonderful for
doing this I mean talk about virtue
signaling here she is Russia Iran and
their affiliated militia are the ones
responsible for what the UN called a
complete meltdown of humanity and they
are showing no mercy no mercy despite
their territorial conquest even now no
mercy in the last 24 hours alone
pro-assad forces reportedly killed at
least 82 civilians including 11 women
and 13 children and it is up to each and
every one of us here to defend those
rules to the Assad regime Russia and
Iran three member states behind the
conquest of and carnage in Aleppo you
bear responsibility for these atrocities
by rejecting un ICRC evacuation efforts
you are signaling to those militia who
are massacring innocents to keep doing
what they are doing
denying or obfuscating the facts
as you will do today saying up is down
black is white will not absolve you to
the Assad regime Russia and Iran your
forces and proxies are carrying out
these crimes your barrel bombs and
mortars and airstrikes have allowed the
militia in Aleppo to encircle tens of
thousands of civilians in your ever
tightening noose okay so she is
obviously condemning Russia Iran Syria
only one problem she's
I did with Russia Iran and Syria her
administration sided with all three of
those they left us odd in power the the
Hillary Clinton you remember Hillary
Clinton called Hassan reformer the media
used to treat Assad with kid gloves
these to pretend that he was a good guy
in the region Iran has been empowered
massively by the same administration
that cutting a nuclear deal with Iran
giving them the capacity to broaden
their economy give him a hundred fifty
billion dollars open their economy to
the world allows them to continue
funding terrorism including terrorism in
Syria and in Iraq and as far as Russia
obviously the Obama administration has
been super warm toward Putin they've
allowed Putin to do anything that he
could possibly want to do they've
allowed Putin to take over everything
and so the hypocrisy of left when it
comes to criticizing Russia is really
amazing the pocket of the left is now
ripping on Russia for what's going on in
Syria they're the ones who handed it
over to Putin and on point something
else out here too and that is that
there's this weird idea that is
prevailed in inside the Obama
administration that you can shame bad
people into doing good things if you
just shame them and they'll do the right
thing right you remember Michelle Obama
with her bring back our girls hash tag
after Boko Haram the terrorist group in
Nigeria kidnapped a bunch of schoolgirls
she held up that hashtag like Boko Haram
cares what you hatch tagged you remember
that after Putin invaded Ukraine Jen
Psaki of the State Department she
tweeted hashtag United for Ukraine did
that get Putin out of Ukraine of course
not it didn't do anything but this is
this all extends back to the same
mentality as Gandhi so Gandhi was a big
fan of nonviolent resistance back in
1938 he said this about the Jews he said
if I were a Jew born in Germany this is
during the Nazi period if I were a Jew
born in Germany and earn my livelihood
there I would claim Germany as my home
even as the tallest Gentile German might
and challenge him to shoot me or cast me
in the dungeon the Jews of Germany can
offer satyagraha that's the passive
resistance under infinitely better
auspices than the Indians of South
Africa of course that was inherently
untrue because the British were not vile
Nazis and the Nazis were in 1946 after
he found out about the Holocaust he
continued to maintain this he said
Hitler killed five the five million Jews
it is the greatest crime of our time but
the Jews should have offered themselves
to the butcher's knife it would have
aroused the world in the people of
Germany they sort of didn't have a
choice and they were slaughtered by the
millions the idea that the world would
have been aroused by knowledge of the
Holocaust is nonsense everybody knew
about the Holocaust well is happening
the contemporaneous documents show that
was the case and the United States
wouldn't even bomb the rail lines so the
idea that you can offer passive
resistance to evil and then that somehow
suffices
that's ridiculous but that's been the
Obama administration policy all the way
through and yes Putin is an evil man
Putin is a deeply evil human being who
has not only expanded Russian borders at
the expense of free peoples he's also
he's also murdered dissidents imprisoned
dissidents imprisoned people who are
Oleg ARCIC who he doesn't like and then
handed their money to other oligarchs
that he does like personally enriched
himself to the tune of 40 billion
dollars supposedly he is he's taken
measures to to destroy lives all
throughout the world I mean Vladimir
Putin is one of the world's worst human
beings he really is one of the world's
worst human beings and the fact that the
Obama administration is now calling it
out after years of propping him up is
truly hypocritical now what's just as
hypocritical is the Republican take on
Putin so there's a poll that came out
today that is really quite disturbing
this a poll from The Economist YouGov
and it talks about net favorability of
Vladimir Putin among Republicans so the
net favorability of Vladimir Putin among
Republicans in in 2016 in to that in
2014 July 2014
Republican net favorability for Putin
meaning the number of people who like
him minus the number of people who hate
him was negative 66 percent so it's
probably like 10 percent like them 676
percent thought that Putin was evil
today today December 2016 that is a
negative 10 percent so that means that
35 percent probably like him and 45
percent think that he's bad okay that's
not good folks that's not good if you're
one of these people who's gotten warm to
Putin because you think that Putin was
mean to Hillary and the enemy of my
enemy is my friend understand he's not
your friend Vladimir Putin has now
played two straight administrations he
played Bush remember Bush saying that he
looked into Putin so I looked into his
soul and he saw something good there and
it turns out that you know McCain was
actually right about this he looked into
Putin's soul and saw KGB and then Obama
came in and said you know the thing
about that Bush he was too hard on Putin
give him a reset button give him more
power everything will be hunky-dory
spent Putin proceeded to screw the
United States once again and expand his
power and our expense and now Trump is
doing the exact same thing and you've
got Republicans going right along for
you've got Republicans going right along
with it and that's dangerous stuff as
dangerous tough Putin is not a good man
Putin is not your ally Putin is not the
guy you can rely on to be a bulwark
against the bad guys he is one of the
bad guys if you want to say that there
are alliances of convenience that you
might be able to draw with Putin from
time to time that's one thing but if you
want to say that Putin is an actual ally
in the war on terror you want to say
that Vladimir Putin is the guy you're
gonna delegate foreign policy to what
Putin knows what he's doing here and he
knows which buttons to push and I think
that it's only a matter of time before
Putin makes a very aggressive move in
Central Asia you know talking about
Kazakhstan or he makes it makes a strong
move against Latvia or Estonia or
Lithuania and then he dares Trump to
stop him and the chances are Trump won't
do anything
the chances are very strong that the
Trump won't do anything the proof is in
the pudding
Trump's election of Rex Tillerson is CEO
of Exxon Tillerson as I said yesterday
this is about Tillerson it's about Trump
the only thing Trump cares about from
Tillerson is presumably what Tillerson
thinks of Putin until her sin in Putin
get along Trump said this yesterday in
Wisconsin here's what he said you know
Rex is friendly with many of the leaders
in the world that we don't get along
with and some people don't like that
they don't want them to be friendly
that's why I'm doing the deal with Rex
because I like what this is all about
and we're gonna have somebody that's
gonna be very special okay so he likes
the fact that Tillerson has
relationships to some of the worst
people on earth this is Obama s language
isn't it better that we should talk to
Cuba isn't it better that we should hang
out with the bad guys that we shouldn't
be talking with the bad guys wouldn't be
better if we were talking to Iran rather
than not talking to Iran this is not a
positive development it's not and for
all the people who are complaining about
what's happening in Syria Trump has no
intention of doing anything in Syria to
help people now maybe you think that's
good maybe you do but the truth is that
there are certain basic truths about
foreign policy that very few people want
to acknowledge the the most fundamental
truth is that when it comes to a choice
between genocide and American
intervention most people will choose
genocide and that's been true
historically for the United States you'd
rather watch from abroad as genocide
happens somewhere then we would get
involved and that's a question that we
ought to be asking ourselves is what
extent is they involvement necessary
should that involvement include
airstrikes or should also include boots
on the ground how much do we
about this and if we're not honest with
ourselves about this question more
people are gonna die while we did there
around but clearly Trump doesn't care
particularly much here's Donald from
spokesperson Jason Miller he asked about
Vladimir Putin's involvement in Syria
do we have that no we don't have that
okay well he said earlier he said that
that hundreds of thousands of people in
Syria being killed we were viewing that
through the wrong lens that's what he
said
on Fox News a little bit earlier today
we should view that through a different
lens it's again no we shouldn't
something is really bad happening and
you can say that we don't have the
wherewithal or we don't have the
resources or we don't have the will to
stop it but to pretend that Obama's
awful awful awful about Syria and then
pursue exactly the same policy and
actually warm to trump is more than a
little bit hypocritical the same thing
is happening by the way that Russian
hacking of course the the the real
reason that Republicans shifted on Putin
is not because they thought the Putin
was fighting Isis hey the real reason
the Republicans shifted on Isis is the
same reason they shifted on WikiLeaks
when WikiLeaks was targeting the
American military we hated WikiLeaks
then it started targeting Hillary and a
lot of Republicans said hey WikiLeaks
they're great they know how by the way
they they went from a 47% net
unfavorable rating among Republicans in
2014 to a net 27% favorable rating among
Republicans now WikiLeaks hey they still
are releasing American military
information but we're cool with that
because they're serving our purposes
again this just goes to show you that
most people down deep don't really care
about anything remotely approaching
intellectual honesty they care much more
about does it serve my interest does it
not serve my interest and that's true
also of the Russian hacking so long as
the Russian hacking we think helped
Trump it's okay if the Russian hacking
had helped Hillary we'd be over the moon
about it'd be the end of the world we'd
be losing our minds but if you're bob
Corker right the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee I'm a guy who's
become sort of an ally of Trump he says
that there's no reason we should have
our hair on fire about Russian hacking
I'm assuming that plenty of people are
attempting to listen to my phone calls I
mean that's the way intelligence is
gathered so the hacking piece the
hacking piece is
I mean I don't think we ought to have a
hair on fire about that I'm sorry I mean
that's what people do it's what you do
with that and I mean we need to guard
against it we need to do everything we
can to make sure that it doesn't happen
is certainly in our office we're doing
everything we can to make sure that our
computer systems are not hacked and
right this is obviously raising alarms
for everyone but but at the end of the
day trying to understand what Russia is
doing not only here in the United States
but in elections around the world is an
important thing for us to know right
we shouldn't have our hair on fire about
it right we should we should just I
don't even know what that means and I'm
not sure I would like to see Bob corkers
hair on fire just for the thrill of the
the fun of it I mean just the deputy dog
of him running around where this hair on
fire is still speaking with the slow
cadence would be would be amusing but we
have to sign off here but there's a lot
more to come we are going to talk about
some good things that Donald Trump has
been doing the man obviously has
tremendous personal magnetism and will
talk about the evidence of that that
daily wire.com to to view the rest of
the show you subscribed there $8 a month
you if you subscribe now an annual
subscription you get a free copy of my
book true allegiance signed by me and we
do have a daily wire store coming in the
very near future and you'll get
discounts there we have all sorts of
goodies coming for members daily
wire.com for that or you can listen
later at iTunes and SoundCloud and and
YouTube and and check us out there we
are the largest conservative podcast in
the United States
[Music]
you